i think that there is so much value in
having diversity in venture we can spur
a lot of economic innovation from
different spaces if we have different
viewpoints involved
my name is paige dougherty i'm one of
the founding partners of behind genius
ventures which is an early stage venture
firm and i'm also the author of an
illustrated children's book about
venture capital it's called seed to
harvest it's a simple explanation of
venture capital it goes through
a lot of like different how venture
investors look at the world and evaluate
companies
and and like some of the concepts like
sourcing which you can see here the
farmers like selecting their seeds and
here is the companies i honestly wanted
to write this book so i could explain to
my parents what i wanted to do my dad's
an engineer and my mom's an artist and
you know didn't really have any context
for tech and now i have a bigger purpose
with it to inspire young women and
people of color to get interested in
venture investing specifically because i
think that there's an incredible impact
that can be had i think that you can
come from any background and be
successful it's all about knowledge
access and connections
[Music]
in terms of what i want my legacy to be
is i want
every little girl to think that she has
the option to work in venture not
necessarily go into it but have the
option to i think
being a very public figure in venture
for me is important so that i can reach
those people that may come from
different backgrounds and not have had
the resources that were made available
to others
i thought when i was growing up that
venture meant you had to come from
generational wealth which i think is a
fundamental
untruth so my whole goal with what i'm
doing with behind genius ventures and
writing this book is to
broaden
and make venture more transparent so
that more people can have a seat at the
table
[Music]
you